so why does interactive sex have almost
what is it a hundred million views or is
it this title that everyone just has to
click on so I get a lot of that too
people are like well it's called
interactive sex yes that is absolutely
true but you know how many videos out
there have the word sex in it a lot uh I
wish it was true because you know what I
would do it I wouldn't be here right now
I'd be in a flying yacht because I would
make every video called interactive sex
and I would be a millionaire but it
doesn't it's not just that it is part of
it the interactivity of it is you know I
think that's more the most successful
interactive videos and it came out at a
time I think a lot of it was timing the
fact that is interactive and the fact
that you watch it and you are really in
control of what's happening is is
something somebody sitting there is like
oh I can I can choose what happens to
this idiot great and then it kind of it
just you know you get people to watch a
whole bunch of videos instead of just
one um but you know it's it's i don't
know i think it's it's good good writing
um good performance not even a sara lee
by me but it's a you know a good
performance and its interactive sex and
it just it just moves it has like a life
of its own so yeah I don't think it's
just it's not just the title I wish wish
it was just the title because I just
interacted to do really well you know
I've got been apart written many
Interactive's and most of them you know
on the channel totallysketch are in the
deep into the millions even on my own
channel which is not as big as others
you know my Interactive's at least in
the total amount is is you know over
over a million and I'm like I'm a
smaller entities compared to some of the
other ones what was the first video that
you did that got into the thousands or
just really surprised you with the
amount of views that ever said well the
first video I did I mean I didn't know I
was doing a YouTube I didn't I just knew
it was in the video as an actor that
loved comedy but it was um the true like
a true Hollywood story of keyboard cat
and that I don't that in the millions
but that isn't definitely on the half a
million but I danette the next one that
I did that kind of went really big was
um is a parody of paranormal activity
called sexual activity and i remember
when i was talking to Michael Gallagher
was
director we were talking is like I want
to shoot this like tomorrow do you have
any idea so we talked about the night
before and then just shot it and it was
timed with the movie like that's a lot
of it if we did it five months after the
movie they would have done okay so it
looks I mean it looks like the movie I
mean it looks it looks like a true
Paradiso sexual activity uh kind of
known for that again with the word sex
in it
you